はするんですね 人間にはこの八十年で
百年で死ぬぐらいじゃなくて
やっぱり千年二千年でも生きていられるぐらいのカルマはエネルギーは強いんです
我々の生まれてくるカルマがね
千年二千年でも生きていられるんです
正しく使えば でもずっと前からはね
人間の体の構成がね あんまり欲で欲で欲で欲でいじめられて早く死ぬようになっている
だから千年二千年寿命延びてくると
もうこんな遊びばっかしで欲だけでは絶対生きていられない
昔あったと仏教の話にありますから
人の寿命はね もう八千年とかね
七千年とかもう八万年とかになってる時あったんだと
やっぱりその時は特則は欲がない
怒りがない 嫉妬がない
だからみんな落ち着いていただろうと思いますよ
自然も破壊しないで 法則にきちんとぴったし合うように
お互いに戦うことなく
そういう風になっていくと
もう長生きはできます
今の我々は自分のやっぱりカルマを早く殺してしまっちゃうんですね
もう 1日の人間使う欲の量を見ると
やっぱり やっぱり二百年ぐらいのカルマは消えちゃうだろうと思いますよ
で 金儲かることにしたって
もうふさわしくないぐらい金儲かりたがるでしょ
仕事をして何か物をそこで売ったならば
そのものから自分得るプロフィットっていうのは
いわゆる経済的に決まってないかもしれませんだけど
なんとなく良心的に決まってるものあるんですね
これぐらいの私はこれぐらいお金あればいいと
それで何か物を一つ作って
それで一生を食おうと思っちゃうでしょうに
もしその分余計なお金取っちゃったら
もう自分の寿命のカルマがもうほとんど使ってしまったことになっちゃうんですね
そういう風にカルマの扱い方が悪い
だからもうガタガタ そうでなくて
人間というのは死ぬまでは十分使えるカルマで人間で生まれるんです
正しく使えば まあそれぐらいの話なんですが
で カルマからは逃げられないっていうことは今お分かりになるでしょうと思いますね
眼耳鼻舌身で認識しているんだから
それはカルマの結果なんです
ですから 見たんだからといって罪は犯すわけじゃないんです
こっちいろんなものが絵をかかってるんだと
それ見た 見ただけで別にそれは善でもなし
不善でもなし 過去世の過去のカルマの結果だけ
見て あ これは綺麗ですね
これ買いたいなと思っちゃうと
この心の動きが生まれてくるんです
それはカルマであって
見て綺麗それで終わってる人は新しいカルマを作ってない
だから僕らは見たら見えていると言いなさいと
ヴィパッサナーでは そこで新しいカルマは作らないんです
音を聞くと あの人私の悪口言ってるんではないかと
私を貶してるんではないかと思っちゃうと
ものすごい怒りのカルマを作っていて
人が苦しむ 音ですと ただ
すぐそこでも過去のカルマのせいで聞いた
それだけ 終わりと それは自分の性格と一体になってところはもう悟りの境地を行っているんですね
その悟った人にだけ 見たものは見ただけで止まることはできるんです
カルマがなしに 我々には無理なんです
ですから もういいものを見たら
欲心ですか 八種類の欲心がありましたから
そこら辺でいろんなものを生まれてくる
悪いものを見ちゃったら
二種類の怒りの心が生まれてくる
そういうのはカルマであって
カルマが今我々眼耳鼻舌身の識はカルマの結果である
やっぱりこの窓口から入る情報を我々は受け取ってから
いわゆる水道心があるでしょ
カテゴリーに入れる それから生まれる心の流れは全部カルマなんです
ここまではカルマではない
ではない ただの結果だけ
行為だ そこで善悪の結果
それぐらいで もう三つは残ってますが
それでちょっと これも言葉を覚えておいてください
それは仏教の心理学的なところはこれだけで終わるんです
一般政治学のこと これからもう三つあります
今日何心でしたっけ？あひーとこきえつ
あ 疑いそ心ですね あひーとこきえつ言って
五分ぐらいで終わります
えーと ウペッカーサハガタン
長いかな 俺はパンチャ・ドゥーアラ・ワッジャラ・チッタ
パンチャ・ドゥーアラ
これ繋げますよ これからこのまた無因心三つありまして
キリア・チッタと言うんです
キリアというのは唯移さ
この三つございます アヘッとか無因
無因というのは貪瞋痴でもない
不貪不瞋痴でもないということで
いわゆる善でもない悪でもない
キリアというのは唯移さ
ただ働きだけなんです
ちょっとした心理的な働きが起こるんだと
そういう心は三つ いわゆる体の行動は全部心でやらなくちゃいけないんだからね
三種類の働きがあります
一番目はシャグ ウペッカー・サーガタン
いわゆる喜びでも何でもない普通の感覚なんですけど
五蘊因転心と呼んで 五蘊というのは眼耳鼻舌身
五蘊 因典って何ですかね
パンチャドワーラ アーワジャナという言葉で
この我々の体になんとなくこの何か機能があるんですね
この対象を受け取っちゃうんですね
外の情報はもういつでも準備OK状態にいるんですね
この入ってちょうだいと
入ったらすぐそれを認識する
ですから もし誰かが私の体を触ったら
触った瞬間そこにすぐ意識いっちゃうんですね
すぐそこに行くように準備しているんです
いくら私は本をこうやって読んでいたっても
誰かが指にでも触れちゃったら
すぐそこ知っちゃうんですね
あの 何て言いますか あの起きてる状態
ヴィパッサナーではなかなか起きてくれませんだけど
この対象を認識するためにはものすごい素早く体が起きてるんですね
いくら瞑想していたっても
何かどこかちょっと微かな音が入っちゃったら
すぐそこも聞いてるんです
ですから 我々の五門 眼耳鼻舌身は
この対象が引くために
なんか起きれるような状態があるんですね
その心に五門因典というんです
その五門因典はどこでも生まれる
目にも生まれる 鼻にも生まれる
五門因典なければそこには感覚はなし
触っても切ってもわからない
ですから麻薬 麻薬じゃなくて麻酔なんか打っちゃったら
体の五門因典という心が生まれなくなっちゃうんです
だから切っても知らない
聞いても聞こえない 音はあるのに
耳に触れてるのに感じない
まあ医学ではそれはもう細胞やら物質的な説明をしてますけど
やっぱり生命としてはやっぱり何かの心の機能をカットしているんですね
そこでそれは五門因典
2番目はあの シャグーのイモンインテン
イモンインテンはもっと難しい理解する
それはこの意識 いろんな妄想
概念やらいろんな考え方が頭の中にぐるぐるぐるぐる回っちゃうでしょ
いつでも考えてるんですね
考えずにいられないんです
同じく我々の心も何か考えようという
いつでも準備OK状態に
状態にいるんです 対象を引き
引き起こす状態にいるんです
体と同じなんですね 体にはいつ何が触れてもすぐ知るような感じで
心にすぐもう意識が生まれるように
概念が生まれるようにあるんです
それはもうすごい早くても一回イモンインテン生まれたら次もう概念が回転する
次から次へと そういうわけで
瞑想っていうのは簡単そうでなかなかやりにくいのは
そういうごく普通の心理学なシステムだからなんです
統一使用しようと思ったっても
こちらで五門因典が働いている限りはね
統一にはなりっこないんです
そこはもう それいくらか体を落ち着いたところで
イモンインテンがもう抜群に活動し始めるんです
ありとあらゆる妄想が生まれて
そこも落ち着いたところで
やがてやっと統一状態が生まれてくるんです
だからもう次元を破ることだと
この瞑想 禅定の世界と言っているんですね
そこで 3番目のキグーの
いわゆる楽しいということ
楽しい ショーキシン ショーっていうのは笑うことですね
笑うことは起こる心があります
で まあ私は伝統的にアビダンマにあることだけ伝えますけどね
個人的にはアビダンマについて僕はいろいろもう意見がありますけど
それはまあ学問的な授業だったら言いますけどね
まあちょっとまあこれは学問的じゃなくて仏教の話だから
まああることしか言えません
えーと この笑う時は生まれる心
それも単なる働きだけですよとここで言ってるんですね
カルマではない カルマにならない
でもこの心は阿羅漢にだけ生まれるんだと
阿羅漢になった方々 悟った方々も笑うんです
でもその笑い方は違うんです
我々みたいにゲラゲラ笑うこともなし
私たちは人のおかしいことを見て笑っちゃうでしょ
大体私でも皆様方笑わせたければ
まあちょっと何か変なことを言わなきゃ笑わないんです
ごく普通当たり前のことを言ったって誰も笑わない
ですから 我々の笑い方の法則も決まってるんです
変であれば笑うと その中でも変だから否定的に笑うと
もありますよ あるいはあまりも変で面白く笑うと
ですから まあ一般の人々の笑うことは
大体笑って楽しいんだから欲心なんですね
あの 8種類の欲心 貪瞋瞋
その中でも喜怒 喜怒貪瞋瞋は四つしかない
ですから それはもうやっぱり罪を犯してるんです
笑っちゃうと 今日から笑わない方がいいんです
チャックをかけて で 阿羅漢になった人
すべての煩悩なくなった人だけ
なんか世の中の苦しみを見て
みんなもうやっぱりなんて言いますか
この無明の中に回転しながらね
いわゆる解脱の道そのそこにあるのに見つからなくて苦しんだり
たまにやっぱりなんか自分には智慧がありますからね
自分が救われているんだと
そういう恐ろしい世界から
もうやっと心が解放しましたという落ち着きが生まれてきて
なんとなく楽しく あ よかったという雰囲気が生まれるんだそうです
その笑顔 喜怒生喜心と言うんです
わざわざそう言うのは
お釈迦様は笑っていたんですね
もしかするとそのためだと
俺の個人的な意見なんですけどね
私から見れば お釈迦様というのはなんかすごいもうなんか俗っぽく言えばね
ものすごい素晴らしい哲学者で
またすごい面白い方で
もう何聞いていても面白くて
またすごい抜群の智慧があって
言うこともすごく面白く
じーんと心に入るように言うというふうなことがあって
人がとんでもないことをしちゃうと怒ることをなく
かえってすごくそこにユーモアが入れちゃうと
というふうな性格のように
それをお釈迦様 一般の人間で見る場合はね
お釈迦様もどこらのもう一人の人間だよと思ったら
そういう性格なんです
人はもうとんでもない悪いことしちゃって
もう怒ったり あるいはもうぶん殴ったり刑務所に入れたりするぐらいのことをしたら
やれやれなんとかと言って
なんかもうその問題はすごく明るく笑顔で扱うと
そうすると罪を犯した人はなんとなくじーっと心が落ち着くし
問題は解決できるし そこですごい哲学者だから
やっぱり人間というのは愚か者だから
そんなことやらなくてもいいのに
やっぱりアホだからやったという気持ちで見てるんだから
ですから お釈迦様よく笑っていらっしゃったような感じがする
そこでお釈迦様笑ったら
なぜブッダが笑ったんですか？とお坊さんたちは聞く
なぜならば無駄に笑わないんだから
何かすごいわけがあるんだ
それでお釈迦様は私はこういうこういう餓鬼を見てこんな苦しんでいるね
そこで笑った という風な説法の話になるんです
ですから 阿羅漢たちとブッダお釈迦様が笑う時生まれた心と特別な心は入れてますけど
アビダンマにはそういうふうにいいかなと思いますけどね
あるある ある一種の人間だけにある心というか
やっぱり一つは仏教では一般の人々笑うのはやっぱり欲の心で笑ってますよと
それはまたかえってその通りであると
その心の 3つも有色心で先でもなく後でもなく
それから無因転計とも言うんですね
それを申しまして この欲界の心は終わります
もうちょっとまた残ります
あります それは次は夜会は五十四ですけど
まだ四十四まで行ってない
あと十六残ってます じゃあ今日はこれで終わります
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました